sunshine laundromat is a small
laundromat in Brooklyn that as you pass
through it you realize has a little more
than meets the eye because in the very
back is a secret door which opens onto a
bar filled with some of the greatest
pinball machines ever assembled into one
location
we're Alice obscura and these are in
frequently asked questions with Peter
Rose the owner of sunshine laundromat
what is the weirdest thing you found in
a laundry machine I've only found
day-to-day objects in laundry machines
but actually in one of the drop-off
orders one of our attendants once found
used i'm peter owner of sunshine
laundromat in Greenpoint Brooklyn and
today we'll be answering some questions
for Atlas obscura
[Music]
our drunk people better at pinball or
laundry I would say likely pinball drunk
people doing laundry I think they're
just making their clothes wet taking
amount and shoving them in a bag pinball
is probably the the best place for
drunks if you can add a third hidden
business behind the bar what would it be
my idea would be if we could have
something that involved more dogs a
business with large dogs a kennel a
litter of puppies back there does your
liquor license cover the laundromat our
license does cover the laundromats it's
somewhat by choice and largely by
confusion the community board our
attorneys and even the State Liquor
Authority I think we're just so confused
by this whole thing that they just said
yes
where can patrons stand if they want to
simultaneously enjoy the aroma of a
laundromat and bar in the bathroom the
middle ground have you curate the items
in your vending machine many of the
items in the vending machine are just
random articles that I'll see in a store
that would physically fit in a vending
machine but one would not expect to find
in there sewing a dollar for two dollars
I think was just really just an attempt
at humor and it's highly profitable it's
our best margin item here but much to my
surprise people started buying it on a
near daily basis and we had one person
that came in here bought it and he
thought there was like a hidden gift
behind it presumably something worth
thousands of dollars so he was a little
disappointed when he found out he got a
dollar for two dollars has there ever
been a combo laundry and pinball machine
who wrote this question
you're a genius this is amazing we're
gonna talk who wouldn't want to play a
laundry pinball machine quick add the
bleach softener Netflix just approached
you about making a pinball and or
laundry themed series what's the title
of the show and what is it about title
of the show
sunshine laundromat it'd probably have
to be about dogs oh we have subliminal
dogs everywhere hidden dogs it's a
treasure hunt just nothing in the bar
area apartment of help us if you could
be burned inside a pinball machine which
one would you choose oh wow all-time
favorite could be medieval madness so I
might have to spend the rest of my life
inside there as great as many of the
other games are that's one that I can
come back to endlessly does this place
have a lost-and-found if so what's the
weirdest thing that's ever been in there
we do have a lost-and-found it's in one
of our broken old dryers that somebody
set ablaze oh the weirdest thing that's
ever been in there I think for a while
it may have been a nativity scene
although I'm not sure that was lost that
might have been a little more deliberate
what's the most money you've ever
physically held in quarters I would say
the most I've ever lugged over to the
bank in one trip is probably about five
thousand dollars at which point I needed
to visit a chiropractor
what questions haven't we asked that we
should that might be how did we know we
were successful beyond looking at
finances I think one of my favorite
instances was when we received a
certified letter from the State Liquor
Authority offering their condolences
about the place not existing meanwhile
they just couldn't find us which is so
flattering that the whole speakeasy
concept actually worked in what ways is
pinball a metaphor for life
[Music]